c'est un véritable changement que semble
annoncer le rapport de la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre la
drogue désormais si ce rapport est suivi
par le gouvernement la lutte contre la
toxicomanie ne serait plus réservée au
cannabis à l'héroïne ou à la cocaïne
mais elle engloberait alcool tabac et
médicaments ces substances légales entre
guillemets sont statistiquement plus
nuisible que les drogues réputés comme
donc l'héroïne ou la cocaïne
soixante mille morts dus au tabagisme
vingt mille à l'alcoolisme et une large
utilisation de médicaments dans les cas
de suicide la politique envisagée par le
gouvernement deviendrait donc globale
voici les explications de joël bruandet
et filippi un chasselas l'alcool le
tabac ainsi que certains usages des
médicaments voilà la cible du rapport
d'étape rendu public aujourd'hui
selon le texte de la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre la
drogue
il faut désormais prendre en compte
l'ensemble des pratiques qui provoque
une dépendance et non se contenter de
lutter contre l'héroïne ou la cocaïne et
les chiffres sont là pour prouver que
les drogues légales font un nombre
considérable de victimes chaque année le
tabac
soixante mille morts l'alcool
vingt mille morts alors que l'héroïne
fait moins de 1000 morts et que le
cannabis n'a provoqué directement aucun
décès cela ne signifie pas que l'héroïne
ou la cocaïne soit moins nocive mais
plutôt qu'une approche globale s'impose
en fonction de la toxicité des produits
chez produire des spécificités mais le
le problème majeur c'est que chacun peut
entraîner des usages excessifs des abus
et puis le point commun tous ces
produits on ne
du tabac c'est les troubles les troubles
du comportement le rapport recommande
également une redéfinition de la
politique pénale
en clair moins sanctionné le simple
usage pour se concentrer sur le trafic
c'est là que les avis divergent entre
ministères quand je pense que le
démantèlement des réseaux de drogue dans
les quartiers
une chose essentielle si nous voulons
nature et la reconquête républicaine
et que cela
les décès seraient fâchés
de la dépénalisation
giles officiellement le rapport ne prône
pas la dépénalisation des drogues douces
certains pourtant le lit entre les
lignes